أفضل أفضل أفضل أفضل
الأفضل ، لا ، لست متأكدًا من صعوبة
الاختيار لا ، ربما لا ، من الصعب جدًا
حقًا أن أختار
أفضل أنواع المعجنات في باريس يمكن أن يكون أمرًا صعبًا حتى
لو كنت واحدًا من أفضل المعجنات في العالم.  أفضل
طهاة المعجنات مؤخرًا ، عملت نينا ماتيا
كمديرة إبداعية للمعجنات
في مقهى بوشكين الشهير في باريس ، وقد صوتت
طاهٍ معجنات للعام مرتين
في سن الثلاثين
، وهي سلطة في كل ما يتعلق
بالمعجنات ، وبعد الكثير من المداولات
تمكنت من تضييق نطاق  أفضل
الحلويات الباريسية الحلوة لثلاثة فقط ، لذا
إلى أين سنذهب إلى نينا ، فهذه هي المحطة الأولى
حيث سنذهب ، وهذا هو الملف
الصغير من Sahelian Jackie ، يمكننا
الذهاب إلى الداخل
أحب هذا المكان وكل هذا أفضل طعام ،
إنه لطيف جدًا أنا ذاهب  لمحاولة تادا ،
إنه المفضل لدي ، لذا كلما كان ذلك أفضل
مثل بريوش كبير مع شراب بداخله ، عادةً
ما يكون مسرة أوروبية وشانتي في الأعلى
أحيانًا فاكهة على الأرض ، إنها
معجنات فرنسية نموذجية طيور بسيطة جدًا مثالية
وهذا هو الأفضل.  أي
موسيقى باريسية
هنا نقوم بالحقن ، إنه
أفضل
تعليق على الإطلاق ، إنه أفضل تعليق على الإطلاق ،
هناك شوكولاتة عسل يسوع هذا
هو مانجو باشن فروت ، إنه يذوب في
فمك تمامًا ، يمكنك أن تشعر
بالمانجو وفاكهة العاطفة والكاميرا
تمامًا  أشعر وكأنك تعرف ما إذا كان
كل واحد لدي مائة علبة
[موسيقى]
فهذا هو آخر متجر في ولاية يوتا
وهذا متجر خاص بسيط بالنسبة لي إنها
المرة الأولى التي أتيت فيها إلى هنا
وأنا متحمس جدًا وسأحاول  يشعر الحذاء
بالإثارة ،
لذا من الأفضل أن يكون فقط من عيد الميلاد ،
فلا أحد أفضل مجانًا لأنهم
غاضبون ، فنحن نفتقد الأشخاص الذين
يقضون وقتًا ممتعًا في وظيفة لطيفة